[Musique]
bonsoir je le vérifie que vous êtes
encore réveillé ce soir en parle d'eux
aïe bon donc ce soir parle de
renaissance ce soir je vous parlais de
renaissance de la filière du livre
renaissance des librairies de proximité
renaissance du libraire imprimeur avec
gutenberg renaissance en fait de liens
et de contacts sociaux dans les
centres-villes et de contacts proches
alors l'histoire commence il ya quelques
années où j'enchaînais les jobs
j'étais directeur de projet dans des
grands projets informatiques et tous les
2-3 ans les projets définis et j'avais
la question stop ou encore parce que je
continue la même société est ce que je
refais ce que je faisais ce que je
faisais déjà dans une société dans une
autre société ainsi de suite voilà j'ai
enchaîné
mais j'avais un problème de fond qui
était il manque un truc c'est hyper
intéressant c'est intellectuellement
stimulants c'était génial c'était des
énormes projets informatiques
mais c'était pas très à l'aise je ne
trouvais pas très utile ou pas très
centré vers les autres le déclic j'ai eu
entre deux jobs en 2012 lors d'un dîner
en fête qui avait lieu à viroflay où ma
femme était à côté était assise à côté
d'une personne qu'elle ne connaissait
pas et qui s'appelle alexis et qui lui
parle de l'impression à la demande aux
états unis
l'impression à la demande ça résonnait
pour ma femme parce que en fait elle
avait un métier des diplômes du livre ça
résonnait pour moi parce qu'en fait
c'était quelque chose on pouvait
réorganiser un modèle sociétal on
pouvait organiser plein plein de choses
autour de ça donc je me suis dit il ya
quelque chose qui peut être fait je vais
pouvoir et à la tension accrochez-vous
lutter contre la solitude
alors là je vais vous expliquer un petit
peu comment passe de la librairie et la
solitude parce que c'est pas forcément
hyper évident comme ça en fait je me
suis dit que la librairie un lieu
d'échangé lieu de contacter un lieu 2 à
2 2 1 ayant un lien tout simplement dans
un centre ville
un lien qui permet en fait grâce à ce
petit média de pouvoir dire j'ai aimé
j'ai détesté j'ai adoré
j'ai tu devrais lire j'ai rêvé ça m'a
réveillé mais perd peur c'est tout ce
que voulait en fait après avoir lu un
livre on est différent donc en fait on a
envie d'en parler donc c'est un média
des changes
donc pour moi c'était un lieu où en fait
dans une sonde dans le centre ville ça
permet d'avoir une arme dans le
centre-ville l'âme c'est bien mais en
fait aujourd'hui quand vous vouliez la
concurrence d'internet vous regardez les
ventes en ligne vous regardez un certain
nombre de choses en fait c'est difficile
les libres et de proximité peuvent
peuvent ne pas ne pas durer donc j'ai
pris mon bâton de pèlerin et puis je me
suis dit qui connaît rien au secteur
parce que je venais du monde de
l'informatique donc pas du tout bon de
l'édition et je me suis dit tiens on va
les voir en fait un petit peu ce qui se
passe alors en franche sais pas si vous
savez il ya 700 mille références 700
mille références pour vous donner une
petite comparaison l'âge d'or du cd
quand on allait quand on était un peu
plus jeunes on va dire l'âge d'or du cd
qu'on allait acheter nos cd il y en
avait à peu près 100 120 milles et
pourtant on avait l'impression que dans
les rayons dans des magasins bien connus
dont je tairai le nom là mais on avait
l'impression qu'il y avait partout donc
là on est sur un marché qui est cette
fois plus gros il ya à peu près 70
milles nouveautés par jour 70 78
nouveautés par an pas ça fait à peu près
200 nouveautés par jour 200 nouveautés
donc c'est quelque chose qui colossales
et qui va avec ce qui va très très vite
ensuite
deuxième constatation qui était
effarante la surproduction
c'est l'édition est basé sur de la
surproduction en 2012 et 890 millions de
livres qui ont été imprimés pour rien
pour 430 millions donc ça veut dire que
vous avez 43% des ventes qui vont partir
en purée à 990 millions d'euros de deux
livres ça fait quoi si vous les mettez
en pile comme ça c'est ce que j'ai mis
comme ça ça fait cinq mille kilomètres
de rayonnages et sa sa part chaque année
à la poubelle
donc en fait je me suis dit il ya
quelque chose à faire dernier point vous
avez je veux pas vous sidéré mais vous
avez 40 % des flux qui rentre dans une
librairie qui concerne des invendus qui
rentrent et qui sortent 40% de ce qu'ils
rentrent et qui sort c'est une moyenne
sur la france sont liés à des invendus
donc ça fait 117 millions de lits
en fait qui vont être livrés chez les
libraires ils sont invendus donc ils
repartent en fait le distributeur là on
rajoute que 40 à 60% des livres sont
imprimés à l'étranger ok vous rajouter
encore en plus des millions de
kilomètres de livraison à domicile le
bilan le bilan carbone de la filière du
livre même si c'est quelque chose qui se
recycle c'est moins pire que d'autres
arguent d'accord mais on pourrait faire
mieux donc on arrive sur une logique en
fait on a énormément de gâchis on a
énormément de problèmes avec le problème
principal
aucun libraires ne peut avoir tous les
livres en stock ce n'est pas possible
regardez-la l'hybride viroflay elle n'a
pas tous les durs en stock 700 mille
références
bonjour à ma femme en passant c'est ça
n'est pas possible donc c'est quoi
l'équation l'équation en fait se dire
qu'on se reproduit c'est un économie de
déchets est en fait le client il est pas
hyper satisfait parce qu'en fait ils
rentrent dans la librairie et il ya
plein de fois il n'a pas ce qu'il veut
donc en fait qu'est ce qui va se passer
c'est qui vient une fois deux fois trois
fois en librairie alors ces librairies
sont sympas tout va bien et il reviendra
il ya peut-être d'autres fois il va se
dire je vais aller sur internet parce
qu'en fait comme ça je suis sûr de
trouver ce que j'ai mais quand vous avez
sur internet en fait ça va réduire les
marges des libraires plus vous réduisez
les marches des libraires moins ils ont
de profit plus en fait ils risquent de
faire faillite
s'ils font faillite en fait ça va ça va
désertifier les centres villes ont
désertifie les centres-villes vous aurez
pu librairie et après vous aurez plus
d'âme dans la libraire dans la dans le
centre-ville ainsi de suite on peut se
retrouver avec des désertification de
centre ville
donc en fait en 2012 grâce à alexis que
je remercie parce que je n'ai pas vu
depuis trois ans mais il est dans la
salle donc le moi si je me suis dit le
plus simple c'est l'imprimé au plus près
du client et au plus près du client
c'est dans la libre et donc il a fallu à
peu près cinq ans pour rendre la
solution opérationnelle
on va n'a créé une solution technique on
a convaincu des éditeurs des
distributeurs des libraires
on a construit un modèle économique qui
tienne la route on a conclu des
partenariats avec des grands industriels
on a mis en place le premier partenariat
les premiers accords et on est poli
première machine
alors quand on arrive avec quelque chose
une grosse machine comme ça en fait qui
permet d'imprimer de relier des livres
en dix minutes de manière complètement
automatique donc vous pouvez faire des
livres de cette taille là mais c'est
aussi cette taille là que je sus de
cette taille là qu il ya une infinité de
formes assez tu joues les montrerai tout
à l'heure ce qui est important c'est que
il a fallu changer complètement les
mentalités des personnes pourquoi parce
que en fait quand on imprime localement
c'est forcément plus cher que l'imprimé
dans des énormes série mais l'intérêt
c'est justement de se dire on évite
toute la surproduction dont je vous ai
parlé on évite les plus inutiles on
évite tous ses coups en fait qu'ils sont
des ruptures de charges et des coûts
salariaux des coudes espace des coudes
logistique des coûts de destruction
découvrir donc on est plus cher en
production mais comment on économise
énormément de coups à droite et à gauche
en fait on devient beaucoup plus
rentables ce qui est rigolo en plus
c'est qu'en fait à partir du moment où
on fait ça tous les acteurs y gagne vous
avez l'éditeur qu'est-ce qui perd
content parce qu'il se retrouve avec
plus de livres qui vont pouvoir est
disponible dans les librairies
donc il est sûr de ne pas rater une
vente on a les distributeurs les
distributeurs c'est ce sont des
intermédiaires donc entre les éditeurs
et libraires qui acheminent les livres
et qu'il ait remporté
on pourrait se dire pas de problème pour
eux ils sont payés quand le livre arrive
ils sont pillés qu'un livre viennent un
peu rois du pétrole entre guillemets
sauf que quand en fait vous allez
chercher un livre pour une librairie au
fin fond de vente entrepôt ça vous coûte
beaucoup plus cher que ce que vous
gagnez donc en fait c'était c'est de ce
sont des stocks déficitaire pour eux
hors série ils nous disent prenez autant
de chiffre d'affaires que vous voulez
sur les petits volumes
parce que de toute façon c'est du
chiffre d'affaires de fissy terre et
donc en fait nous on va augmenter notre
marge donc ils sont contents à des
éditeurs content des distributeurs
content et les libraires on veut
remonter leurs leurs marges nettes en
leur évitant des coûts inutiles et des
stocks inutile donc plutôt content après
en fait il ya un truc qui rigolo à
partir du moment où vous avez plus de
stock
vous avez une infinité de possibilités
vous allez pouvoir faire des albums
photos on va pouvoir d'auto édition
familiale
on va pouvoir c'est la personnalisation
la personnalisation sinon je rajoute une
dédicace dans le livre je vous souhaite
bon anniversaire
on va pouvoir avoir des livres en langue
étrangère on va avoir à pouvoir des
livres d'éditeurs on va pouvoir fait des
bd je vous apporter des livres en fête
pour vous puissiez voir parce qu'en
général quand on dit qu'on fait de
l'impression immédiate en librairie la
première réponse est où là il doit faire
des polycopiés à spirales à peu près
c'est la première et puis après la
deuxième on fait la couleur
this way ou de la couleur ça nous plaît
on est en 16 millions de couleurs je
vous montre après c'est quelque chose
qui est assez assez bluffant donc on
peut faire à jouer et faire tomber ou
sur mesure à ça se fait pas mais on peut
faire donc des bandes dessinées on peut
faire des listes de différentes tailles
on peut faire des livres car et si vous
préférez des livres car et on va pouvoir
faire des livres par exemple là c'est un
livre en anglais sur sur londres et on
va pouvoir faire aussi des lits
agrandi pour du confort de lecture donc
on prend le même livre
on l'a agrandi par homothétie est en
fait ce qui fait que pour certaines
personnes le soir qui n'ont pas envie de
mettre leurs lunettes
c'est par là voilà donc en fait on ouvre
plein de possibilités la dernière
possibilité c'est la dyslexie
aujourd'hui en fait il ya des études qui
sont faites aux états unis où on est en
train de tester en fait des polices pour
les personnes dyslexiques
et c'est assez bluffant on est en train
de travailler dessus aussi dans là pour
voir effectivement si ça fonctionne mais
ça permettrait aux personnes dyslexiques
de mieux lire à partir du moment où vous
avez pas de stock
en fait c'est possible de faire toutes
ces impressions et demain le rêve qu'on
a dans notre société c'est de se dire un
client arrive et il dit votre livre vous
le voulez comment où les stands a
agrandi langue étrangère vous voulez
dyslexique et en fait ça devient
possible donc la myriade de titres que
vous cherchez devient accessible près de
chez vous donc on a tous les éléments
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle
renaissance de la filière du livre on a
créé un nouveau modèle économique
on a la possibilité pour les libres et
de proximité de jouer son rôle sociétal
d'animation centre ville
on a le libraire qui revient libraire
imprimeur à la guitare baer mais c'est
beaucoup plus facile avec moins d'encre
sur les doigts quand même et on a aussi
la possibilité de relier des liens et
des contacts dans les centre-villes 1
donc c'est génial on a fait quatre
naissances en fait quand je vous partage
sa la renaissance qui me paraît la plus
la plus sympa c'est la mienne
pourquoi je vais vous expliquer parce
que je sais pourquoi je me lève le matin
en fait ce qui m'intéresse c'est
d'arriver à faire en sorte que dans
peut-être au fin fond de la creuse et
puissent avoir leur librairie qui
perdure avec effectivement une myriade
de titres et qu'on soit meilleur que la
vente sur internet avec de la
personnalisation
donc aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup de chance
parce que je sais pourquoi je me lève le
matin alors comme toute innovation
serudin il ya des périodes de désert on
se prend des baffes
il ya des tempêtes c'est il faut il faut
ramer fort amer
mais je veux dire comme ceux-ci là on a
tout ça entre nos mains et c'est nous
qui pouvons le faire
merci
[Applaudissements]